(piano notes)
(group chanting)
(group screaming)
- I joined Team Indigenous to be a part
of something bigger than myself.
- It's very important
that we have visibility
as native people.
- I just think it's like
important to see somebody
that looks like you at the top level.
(happy string music)
- [Narrator] This Great Big
Story is brought to you by Delta:
When we venture out into the world,
we see all that we share.
(group chanting and shouting)
(fast string music)
- I'm April Fournier,
and I've been playing
roller derby for five years,
and I'm the co-founder of Team Indigenous.
(fast string music)
Team Indigenous is a roller
derby team made up of
indigenous athletes from
all across the world.
- I think everything looks good,
so we wanna really trust each
other and trust ourselves.
- [April] The lack of representation
for indigenous nations
really fueled the reason that
we wanted to develop this team
and create this space for other
indigenous athletes to join
and compete against all
of these other nations
because we are a nation.
- Nice.
Let's do that again.
(cars driving)
(upbeat string music)
- I've played sports all my
life, and just nothing ever
captured my attention
as much as roller derby.
Living in Maine, no one else
really kind of understands
what it's like to kind of
be the only person of color
skating on a team.
One day I saw a skater that
was on one of the best teams
in the world and she looked like me.
And ultimately from that we
came up with Team Indigenous.
(bright piano music)
Hey everybody!
Hope all is well, so good to see you.
Having teammates from
Canada, all around the U.S.,
and South America, the way
that we're able to communicate
is through video conferencing.
If you haven't seen any of
the updates, our first game is
against team Japan,
which is really exciting.
Team Indigenous will be
at RollerCon participating
in the Nations Tournament.
RollerCon is a roller derby
convention in Las Vegas,
that is seminars, on-skate
training, tournaments.
It's just this really giant celebration of
the roller derby community.
(upbeat piano music)
(whistle blows)
- When I play roller
derby, being in that pack,
being in that mix, there's
just no other feeling like it.
There's so many different
friends and skaters
that look like me.
They talk like me; they have
similar life experiences.
(fast upbeat string music)
- Team Indigenous is absolutely
not about wins and loses;
it's about being able to
take the track together
and see your siblings;
and you're all representing
together on the track as one.
It's not something that you can quantify.
It's not something that you can measure;
it's just community, it's
nation, it's indigenous,
and that's what we are.
(fast upbeat string music)
(bing)